Pour essayer de faire adhérer les gens, la compagnie leur a envoyé une lettre,
leur a parlé des bénéfices du programme
et leur a demandé de les appeler s'ils étaient intéressés.
Ces lettres ont été envoyées,
mais les téléphones sont restés silencieux.
Quand nous nous sommes impliqués, nous avons suggéré un changement.
Au lieu d'une ligne téléphonique,
nous avons suggéré des fiches d'inscription
à côté des boîtes aux lettres dans les bâtiments des gens.
Cela a triplé la participation.
Pourquoi ?
Ce que les autres pensent d'eux importe beaucoup aux gens,
nous essayons d'être vus comme étant généreux et gentils
et d'éviter d'être vus comme étant égoïstes ou profiteurs.
Que nous en ayons conscience ou pas,
cela joue un rôle important dans les bonnes actions des gens.
Donc les petits changements accordant du mérite aux gens pour avoir bien agi
peuvent faire une grande différence.
De petits changements comme passer d'une ligne téléphonique,
où personne n'entendra jamais parler de votre bonne action,
à une fiche d'inscription,
où tous ceux qui passent devant peuvent voir votre nom.
En collaborant avec des gouvernements, organisations, entreprises,
quand nous voulons que les gens fassent plus de bien,
nous exploitons le pouvoir de la réputation.
Pour cela, nous avons une simple liste.
Vous connaissez déjà le premier élément sur cette liste.
Il s'agit d'augmenter l'observabilité
pour s'assurer que les gens entendent parler des bonnes actions.
Attendez, je sais que certains pensent probablement,
impossible que les gens pensent :
« Si l'on m'accorde du crédit pour ma bonne action,
cela vaut le coup. »
Vous avez raison.
En général, ce n'est pas le cas.
Mais quand les gens prennent des décisions en privé,
ils s'inquiètent de leurs problèmes,
de ce qu'ils mettront sur la table pour le dîner
ou de comment payer les factures à temps.
Mais quand nous rendons leurs décisions plus observables,
ils s'occupent plus de l'opportunité de faire du bien.
En d'autres mots, ce qui est si efficace avec notre approche,
c'est qu'elle pourrait activer le désir existant chez les gens de faire du bien.
Dans ce cas, d'aider à éviter une panne d'électricité.
Revenons-en à l'observabilité.
Je veux vous donner un autre exemple.
Il est issu d'une collaboration
avec une organisation qui pousse les gens à voter
en envoyant des centaines de milliers de lettres à chaque élection
afin de rappeler les gens et d'essayer de les motiver à se présenter aux urnes.
Nous avons suggéré l'addition de la phrase suivante :
« Quelqu'un pourrait vous appeler au sujet de votre expérience aux urnes ».
Cette phrase rend cela plus observable de se rendre aux urnes
et a augmenté l'effet de la lettre de 50%.
Rendre la lettre plus efficace a réduit le coût d'un vote supplémentaire,
passant de 70 dollars à environ 40 dollars.
L'observabilité a été utilisée
pour inciter les gens à donner leur sang plus fréquemment
en listant le nom des donneurs dans une newsletter locale
ou à payer leurs impôts à temps
en listant les noms des délinquants sur un site public.
(Rires)
Qu'en est-il de cet exemple ?
Toyota a incité des centaines de milliers de gens
à acheter une voiture éconergétique
en rendant la Prius si unique...
(Rires)
que leur bonne action était observable de loin.
L'observabilité, c'est génial,
mais nous avons tous déjà vu
des gens passer à côté d'une opportunité de faire du bien.
Ils voient quelqu'un demander de l'argent sur le trottoir,
ils sortent leur téléphone et paraissent très occupés
ou ils vont au musée et ignorent la boîte de dons.
Imaginez que c'est la période des fêtes,
vous allez au supermarché et il y a un bénévole de l'Armée du Salut
qui sonne sa cloche.
Des chercheurs de San Diego
ont fait équipe avec une section locale de l'Armée du Salut
pour trouver comment stimuler les dons.
Ce qu'ils ont découvert est amusant.
Quand le bénévole se tient devant une seule porte,
les gens l'évitaient en utilisant l'autre porte.
Pourquoi ?
Ils pouvaient toujours prétendre : « Oh, je n'ai pas vu le bénévole »
ou « Je voulais prendre quelque chose là-bas »
ou « Ma voiture est là-bas ».
En d'autres mots, beaucoup d'excuses.
Cela nous amène au second élément sur notre liste :
éliminer les excuses.
Dans le cas de l'Armée du Salut,
éliminer les excuses, c'est se tenir devant les deux portes
et effectivement, quand ils l'ont fait,
les dons ont augmenté.
Mais c'est là que les choses sont devenues étranges, plus étranges.
Les chercheurs étaient sur le parking
et comptaient les gens entrant et sortant du magasin.
Ils ont remarqué que quand les bénévoles étaient devant les deux portes,
les gens ne sortaient plus du magasin.
(Rires)
Évidemment, cela les a surpris alors ils ont décidé d'étudier la question
et c'est là qu'ils ont découvert une troisième porte, une porte de service
généralement utilisée pour sortir les déchets --
(Rires)
et les gens sortaient par cette porte pour éviter les bénévoles.
Cela nous apprend une leçon importante.
Il faut être très dur quand nous essayons d'éliminer les excuses
car les gens sont créatifs pour en trouver.
(Rires)
J'aimerais passer à un contexte
où les excuses peuvent avoir des conséquences mortelles.
Et si je vous disais que la plus mortelle des maladies infectieuses avait un remède
découvert il y a 70 ans,
un bon remède, qui fonctionne presque tout le temps ?
C'est incroyable mais vrai.
Cette maladie est la tuberculose.
Elle infecte 10 millions de personnes par an
et en tue environ deux millions.
Comme le programme de prévention des pannes,
nous avons la solution.
Le problème, ce sont les gens.
Les gens doivent prendre leurs médicaments
afin de guérir
et de ne pas infecter d'autres personnes.
Depuis quelques années, nous collaborons
avec une start-up de santé mobile appelée Keheala
pour apporter du soutien aux patients durant leur traitement.
Vous devez comprendre, le traitement de la tuberculose est dur.
Nous parlons d'une prise d'un antibiotique très fort
tous les jours pendant six mois ou plus.
Cet antibiotique est si fort qu'il vous fait vous sentir malade.
Il provoque nausées et étourdissements.
Votre urine aura une couleur bizarre.
C'est aussi un problème car vous devez retourner à la clinique
chercher des comprimés une fois par semaine environ.
En Afrique sub-saharienne et autres lieux où la tuberculose est courante,
on parle d'aller à un endroit assez lointain,
de prendre des transports publics compliqués et lents,
la clinique n'est peut-être pas efficace.
On parle de prendre une demie journée de congé par semaine,
alors qu'on ne peut pas perdre son travail.
C'est pire encore si vous considérez le fait qu'il y ait une honte terrible
et que vous ne voulez pas que les gens sachent que vous avez la maladie.
Certaines histoires difficiles sont celles de femmes
qui, dans ces lieux où la violence domestique peut être courante,
nous disent devoir cacher à leur mari
qu'elles viennent de la clinique.
Il n'est pas surprenant que les gens n'aillent pas au bout du traitement.
Notre approche peut-elle vraiment les aider ?
Pouvons-nous les faire tenir bon ?
Oui.
Chaque jour, nous envoyons un SMS aux patients
pour leur rappeler leur prise de médicaments
mais si nous nous arrêtions là,
il y aurait beaucoup d'excuses.
« Je n'ai pas vu le SMS. »
Ou « J'ai vu le SMS, mais ensuite j'ai complètement oublié.
J'ai posé le téléphone et j'ai oublié. »
Ou « J'ai prêté le téléphone à ma mère. »
Nous devons éliminer ces excuses
et nous le faisons en demandant aux patients
de se connecter et de confirmer avoir pris leurs médicaments.
S'ils ne se connectent pas, nous renvoyons un SMS.
Si, après trois fois, ils n'ont pas confirmé,
nous contactons une équipe d'alliés.
Cette équipe les appellera et leur enverra un SMS
pour essayer de les remettre sur la bonne voie.
Pas d'excuses.
Notre approche, qui utilise toutes sortes de méthodes comportementales,
y compris, comme vous avez dû le remarquer, l'observabilité,
était très efficace.
Les patients n'ayant pas accès à notre plateforme
avaient trois fois plus de risques de ne pas finir le traitement.
Très bien,
votre observabilité a augmenté,
vos excuses sont éliminées,
mais il y a une troisième chose dont vous devez avoir conscience.
Si vous avez été à Washington, au Japon ou à Londres,
vous savez que les usagers du métro
font très attention à se tenir sur la droite de l'escalator
pour que les gens puissent passer à gauche.
Malheureusement, ce n'est pas la norme partout
et il y a beaucoup d'endroits où vous pouvez vous tenir des deux côtés
et bloquer l'escalator.
C'est mieux pour les autres
quand on se tient à droite et laisse passer à gauche
mais cela n'est attendu que dans certains endroits.
C'est un phénomène généralisé.
Parfois, on s'attend à ce que nous agissions bien
et parfois pas.
Cela signifie que les gens sont sensibles aux signaux
indiquant qu'ils doivent bien agir dans une situation donnée,
ce qui nous amène à notre troisième et dernier élément sur la liste :
communiquer les attentes.
Dire aux gens :
« Faites une bonne action, ici et maintenant ».
Voici une méthode simple de communiquer les attentes, dire :
« Tout le monde fait une bonne action ».
L'entreprise Opower envoie aux gens, avec leur facture d'électricité,
un petit encart qui compare leur consommation d'énergie
avec celle de personnes dans des maisons de taille similaire.
Quand les gens découvrent
que leurs voisins consomment moins d'électricité,
ils consomment moins.
Cette approche a été utilisée pour inciter les gens à voter ou faire des dons
ou même à réutiliser leur serviette à l'hôtel.
Qu'en est-il de ceci ?
Voici une autre façon de communiquer les attentes :
dire « Faites une bonne action » au bon moment.
Et celui-ci ?
Ce sticker recadre
la tâche mondaine qu'est éteindre la lumière
et la transforme en contribution environnementale.
En conclusion, il y a beaucoup de façons de le faire,
beaucoup de façons de communiquer les attentes.
N'oubliez pas de le faire.
C'est tout.
Notre liste est terminée.
Nombre d'entre vous travaillent sur des problèmes
ayant des conséquences sociales importantes
et vous avez parfois besoin de motiver les gens à faire plus de bien.
Les outils que vous avez découverts peuvent vous aider.
Ces outils ne nécessitent pas de lever des fonds supplémentaires
ou de développer des technologies plus sophistiquées.
Ils nécessitent de tirer profit de la réputation
en augmentant l'observabilité, en éliminant les excuses
et en communiquant vos attentes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)